I'm planning to go on a trip with my sister.
You two must be excited.
Yes!
Do you have a brother or sister?
I have one older brother.
When was the last time you went on a trip with him?
Gee, I can't remember.
My sister and I go on a trip every summer.
Maybe I should plan a trip with my brother, too.
When did you take this picture?
Is this your sister?
Yes!
That's my older sister.
Wow.
We took it last summer when we were in Hawaii.
You two look a lot alike.
Do you have any other siblings?
Yeah!
Well, I have a younger sister.
She looks very different, though.
I envy you.
It must be nice to have so many siblings.
Well, sometimes it's annoying to have sisters.
As an only child, I've always wished I could have a sibling.